moi ce qui me fait vraiment vraiment
j'ai pas d'autre mot pardon banc d'essai
de pouvoir ouais bon me dire que
mentalement tu te déplaces tu vas
quelque part tu as deux motards dehors
ça ça me choque moi pour une une
personne le sait ces macro emmanuel
macron pas je le trouve pas bon ça va
c'est dans les gènes et 10 affaire me
diriger
elle tourne de la mercedes je
souhaite pas de mal à briller moi je
plains la brigitte mais beaucoup bruit
voilà quoi c'est vrai il m'a mis
l'accent à d'abord très beau nom mais le
pouvoir mais pour avoir de l'argent
c'est alain frau diack c'est un
aphrodisiaque heiden ar est il a 78 ans
c'est ma vie j'ai pas des courses qu'on
a pris devoirs a dit massa python qui se
lie les deux motards de venger des
gardes du corps derrière ouais tu veut
de sa vie de première dame chance et ça
ça va faire plaisir emmanuel bach
rocheman sinon gare aux ménages belges
en recul mais aussi parce que j'ai des
on s'est loupé donc week-end avec george
clooney bah alors il est intelligent il
est une capsule
départ sur cuivre et parce que le monde
l'intéressent il aime la politique ils
aiment l'algérie là il a pris beaucoup
d'argent avec ceber aussi les whiskys la
grand place et c'est pour ça qu'on aime
ou on est alors alors je vous dis la
vérité moi j'en ai marre de ça c'est pas
parce qu'on a eu beaucoup de conquêtes
qu'on n'est pas fidèle arrêté comme le
peut ce quelque chose
marc était déjà refoulé c'est pas parce
qu'ils adorent mais c'est vrai ma
première qui dit on ne change pas les
rayures du zèbre mais qui sait ce zèbre
mais c'est vrai non mais ça ne veut rien
dire c'est pas parce que tu as eu
beaucoup de me critiquer surtout avec
beaucoup de femmes et à lui et beaucoup
d'hommes que tu es un fidèle quand
george tenet était quelqu'un après il
était quelqu'un d'autre après il était
quelqu'un de loyal et
avec amal qu'il n'y a pas un seul adrien
alary malawi je pensais qu'en plus j'ai
encore plus risqué pour un mec qu'a pas
une meuf dans sa vie doit elle a eu très
peu de conquête et le jour il est casé
la moindre touche qu'il a exhalé bravo
la reine décide alors que le beau gosse
a profité il a eu peu de conquête à bien
c'est ça ou physiquement et qui avait
pas beaucoup de succès maintenant
notre esthétique mais je n'ai pas été
mieux la mano toi elle était pauvre et
pas très bon dirigeant
non mais je sais que je peux toujours un
stack audard comme je te dis lord à
[ __ ] nous aimons font ces gens ne
râlent castaldi aller margot robbie
alors alors massacre commence à voir que
benjamin castadi comme il est très
fatigué il ne fait plus pratique
je réponds à la question mais oui moi là
bas
voilà mais monsieur webb et si c'était
ça qui jouait dans la joie de jouer
c'est pas le loup si wall street
alors moi moi je l'aimé bien maintenant
je suis plus que jamais revu j'ai revu
des photos genre avec son coeur mais
tous ne suis pas comme en sélection
je vous dis attention faut des liliacées
fodjo bull d'iphoto
les photos des dire voilà vous oui mais
bon pour une nuit je prend justement le
loup de wall street quoi d'art du camion
mais dans le loup de wall street
vraiment le côté vers le nouveau lit et
tout non pas pour une vie pour une demi
heure pour l'arrêter mais le côté folie
est affolée mais vos ennemis ouais
vraiment à quoi louis nicollin kwakwa os
et pour la vue sur des yachts à 14 50
mille balles c'est pour lui
c'est le personnage elle adore le wall
street avec un acteur qui joue l'acteur
mais pas de bêtises moi aussi j'ai adoré
le personnage de nous de wall street
de l'habiter verte il
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
y avait
du sérieux du travaux des terriens
simple tu en voilà même les bad boys
béatrice moi j'irai sur un james bond
j'hésite entre daniel craig pierce
brosnan
daniel craig alors à vous de juger avec
daniel craig obama voit comment vous
voyez le truc c'est toi personne ne sait
non ça reste entre nous oui guillaume
genton
[Applaudissements]
oui bah moi j'ai dû dire
oui quand même fait si
vous avez dit je peux annoncer
officiellement en fin de saison qu'il
n'y a plus aucun hétéro dans cette
guerre je vous soyez un peu de danger
pas que le nom mais voilà au sommet qui
s'est suffi si c'est sûr c'est pas un
problème dans mes castaldi arrête
regarde-toi
mobilité comme ça en rigolant dire un
chien à l'arrière de la voiture à m
arrête on
dirait un moustique devant une vitrine
des cocktails
ben rien tout à l'heure ils sont donc
bien regarder si momo pour persuader
qu'il est hétéro sava
camions bus est une fois taf atteste une
fois tu as demandé à un ami de te faire
une petite île à tristan atteste une
fois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un moment s'en fout il dit les choses à
ma tête je me suis dit tu respecteras
beaucoup sinon mes cheveux noirs damart
et pourquoi tu l'emmènes pas mykonos
avec sourire mais parce qu' il serait
pas et il ferait trop de mal non mais
c'est vrai bah oui parce que tu te
rendrait tout le monde il est ici la
famille ce qui la femme est attendu dès
qu'on en fait un peu toi ça marcherait
il pète un peu style il faut être un peu
c'est terrible de carlos comme ça
[Applaudissements]
déconne et pratique
[Rires]
mr est parti
d'accord ça va décidemment vexé allez
allez tout cela n'est pas fait nous les
léonards
vivent là bas on fait aussi d'en mettre
des sacs de remords on n'en peut plus
alors si on essaie peut-être pas que
jean le poulain encore non maintenant si
personne ne le sait et si c'est pour une
nuit benjamin pour voir si
[Applaudissements]
décidément pas franchement vraiment mis
en balance
la cunca dollars à quoi sinon si c'est
pour la vie il ya quelqu'un dans le film
qui m'a vraiment qui me fait craquer
n'ayez pas peur messieurs c'est bernard
le coq tonnes bah oui d'après ce que
m'ont dit oui là pas un petit
et bernard lecoq otabela là c'est le
grand acteur mais je suis clairement là
visiblement son écran et loisirs
je pense que daniel mot attention daniel
rouan revient très fort un marché du
sexe à
la haye du budo zaballa
bonsoir bon ça me reconnais
sybella wilkes vient de subir une
opération tout c'est de passer
des annonces sont dehors ils souhaitent
pouvoir oui je reconnais peuvent aller
très flou alors je vais demander du oui
ceux qui n'ont pas pour spécialité
l'humour
je vois là c'était
vraiment plaisir voilà voilà voilà vous
êtes là pour quelque chose n'essayez pas
voilà
un
dresseur les yeux le sourire la voit
audrey fleurot personnes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
arthur une à une photo elle est
magnifique et j'aurai la tutelle sur
celui-ci ils ont tapé sur google demeure
ils ont pris la première photo est
arrivé libre au citron 10 et le china
non mais même comme ça les belles mais
ce serait moi je bifurque je chante je
ne m'attends à rien ah tiens oui à
wemmel ans maintenant alors oui bon
c'est un peu juste après on fait alors
pu attendre un petit peu à quoi ça n'a
pas que ça à foot non plus là mais c'est
bape nous croyons n'y a que ça à [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore
j'adore mais vraiment c'est vrai quel
bonheur vraiment ce que les autres
leonardo dicaprio alors je vais dire la
vérité leonardo dicaprio steven finn
plus de chance avec leonardo que toi
bien cela bien sûr
c'est le cas de plus de chance ici
franchement je pense que moi je vous dis
si leonardo dicaprio nous regarde la
whey à moi et me dire moisson de
championnat bordeaux dicaprio je prends
l'avion demain r c'est mon poids en
clown armes dicaprio arrive demain vous
dire oui lui prend l'avion mais pas sa
mitre
[Applaudissements]
jours à peine que
derrière
[Applaudissements]
des amoureuses comme d'helsinn en orbite
manger c'est sûr que tu le paies chaud
même conviction en plus il
agit bien sûr mais je te dis mais c'est
sûr et c'est d'arriver à 13 tu crois
quoi je crois que pierce brosnan ils
pêchent pas béatrice ou 25 tous les
jours c'est bien sûr les jours et
voilà à l'ailé des autres on repassera
non mesdames georges connaître pécho
il adore les tajines
collège dirigeants arrêtent un peu non
mais c'est vrai tigroux oui moi j'ai
toujours été très excité par les femmes
qui ont des prénoms de dom nick le 2 min
koo bernard par exemple ouais nous
affirme daniel moreau comme elle a un
prénom mixte fourré la bouillasse sans
problème
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça se finit en
roue à califourchon
avec l'autre l'infirmière derrière et
l'autre derrière mais qu'est-ce que vous
faire
mais c'est horrible nourriture est la
plus horrible mais ma femme pour une
nuit oui shakira tchèque
il a trompé sa console et
je la prendrai jamais option que je
connais bien moi chaque héros beau
[Rires]
message se dit voilà là c'était plus dur
pour vous bref mais ça reste tout de
même pas mes enfants ma femme qui
regarde la télé
on peut dire plusieurs noms parce que
s'il ya trop de monde il ya dix ans ils
ont donné par tous alors alors alors je
dirais on va lui rappeler les dates de
mykonos quand même
10 au 21 avant de mourir parce que quand
même ça c'est depuis depuis tout jeune
j'ai voilà c'est marina foïs
oui j'avais pas mal moi non plus
et pendant que mes filles sont en train
de pleurer demandé à maman ce qui me
prend de raconter des trucs
je dirais dans une autre vie girolles
san que j'aimais énormément mais bon
j'aime beaucoup je cet homme sépare
alors tu travailles tu te rappelles
engueuler à la maison ça va tu t'en es
bien sorti on est bien sorti c'était
sincère antique et c'est toi qui est
dans la merde
bernard et pascal
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]